and very much so here we go
evangelizing awesome we're ready to go
so let's go ahead and start it off by
saying that hello welcome to simulation
series I'm your host Alan sockin today
we have the pleasure of sitting with
Robert school hey hello thanks thank you
thanks for coming
this is the room where series started I
don't know if you knew that or not room
or series start yeah I was the first one
to see Siri and they launched it on my
couch Oh
Siri was launched on the couch behind
here right now everyone that's watching
right over there that's amazing
yeah it's what a blessed life you know
I've had a series at first I was the
first one I get a ride in the Tesla with
one C clipboard first when I see Dora
first let's see Siri first want to see a
DJI drone included GJ drone over there
yes first DJI drone first Tesla ride
first
Flipboard use Wow and then that's just
start that's just saying wow do they
come to you because you've had so much
interdisciplinary research in the tech
industry I had an audience and people
loved a launch things to them big is now
the world is changing I mean I'm
studying the world in a new way on
Twitter behind us yeah yeah really over
the last four months I've really spent a
lot of time studying Twitter in a whole
new way and it just announced they just
announced good earnings today so their
stock is up he shows that Twitter is on
a little bit of an uprising
Facebook is in there a little bit of
pressure yeah yeah you're one of the
first people that I've met that has said
that my facebook posts get more
engagement than my Twitter posts because
right now the masses are saying that
Twitter is giving me more engagement and
free speech than Facebook is it's still
true today even with the Facebook
newsfeed changes that are happening and
they're still changing and I don't know
that I like the changes but I can tell
why they're doing the changes I'm
studying addiction in a whole new way
exactly
Tristan Harris is also studying
addiction and he just started a new
organization that's taking on the
addictive properties of these networks
and he was urging regulation tap and
particularly with young kids which I
sort of agree with yeah I wouldn't have
gotten there probably four months ago
but I'm really starting to understand
the addictive nature of these things it
was harder for me to give up my phone
for a week than to give up alcohol yeah
yeah call is highly addictive yes yes
exactly that's a great way to put it and
also with that meditation shoot I was
telling you about earlier ten days
there's no tech there talking no eye
contact and it's a beautiful technology
detoxification even something as simple
as just being able to go into a mode on
my phone where I'm just asking to not be
interrupted not silent mode but just
where I'm asking for notifications to
not come through not be in airplane mode
but then when if somebody's emergency
trying to get to me they can break
through it you know it's just on Harris
has been working on that double twice
and they're these companies are a little
naughty with it for instance if you try
to turn off on an iPhone Facebook
messengers notifications or not even
turn them off just turn them down so
that you don't get the the flashing ones
it it puts our it puts a notification of
its own on your lock screen and it
doesn't let you get rid of it you know
because it says oh you have to turn back
on notifications to get rid of that
notification it's like oh they are
naughty they're naughty naughty naughty
and you're so this is this is amazing I
love how you went right into it because
that is kind of what we're gonna talk a
lot about technology and and what you've
been through and where we're going and
kind of some of the ethics and some of
the ways to maximize humans using
technology and beneficial ways
benevolent ways so again we like we like
simulation likes pairing together global
leaders of thought provoking questions
and we also like to
we like to inspire people to build the
future of civilization and so you guys
can find us on patreon we're currently
providing people with awesome benefits
like being able to ask our guests
questions being able to get exclusive
content access to live events ahead of
time access to our guest lists ahead of
time so if you do enjoy what we're doing
please like comment share with other
people and also give us membership
subscribe on patreon and it's
patreon.com forward slash simulation
series so without further ado you
already jumped into it on a lot of the a
lot of the history side of things so you
did so slow belies ur was a massive
public eight it was a publication that
you had started that grew a lot of
interest in the heat in the geeks and
nerds I was early to blogging you know I
started blogging in 2000 and that was
just when Google was getting big and it
turned out blogging was a disruptive
technology based on Google so as Google
got more and more important blogging you
got more and more important at least in
the first four or five years and that's
when you saw all sorts of interesting
tech brands get born TechCrunch and
gadget Gizmodo
yes Huffington Post all got born in that
time period because Google was getting
more important and blogging was the best
way to get high on on Google because we
are all were linking to each other yes
and Google's PageRank was in those days
was based on linking behavior yes now
it's not so based on that but it still
has a little bit of an effect there but
that made me and got me a big audience
or an important audience and that got me
a job at Microsoft which got me inside
of a big beast and got me a point of
view that very few other people still
today have most journalists don't I've
never worked inside a big company
they've worked at media brands but
they've never worked you know inside a
tech company exactly and I've worked now
at a couple of big tech companies a
couple startups you know I went away so
I know what it's like to try a start-up
and failed but I understand what the the
thing about a start-up is all about and
what working on a big
it's all about so then it went from
building up through blogging building
this
following that loves your content you
make content basically relatable to
people in a fun way and that was a big
thing for people too but it's
interesting you know if you talk to
someone of the Facebook executives lives
a couple doors down if you talk to
Facebook they they tell you oh if you do
video today you should make them one
minute long or two minutes at most with
subtitles and make them really flashy a
lot of cuts right to kep because people
are going through their phones looking
for something fun to watch right and
certainly if you want millions of hits
that's the way to go I did sort of what
you're doing which is sit down with an
entrepreneur and do long boring videos
because I I'm generally interested in
their company and what it does and the
product because I want to understand the
dives there are the whole audience of
people that want to be inspired by these
conversations that drive our future and
they want it long-form you four you're
probably familiar with Joe Rogan's
podcast nothing
I mean his video casts go on for three
hours sometimes yeah
so people really enjoy being able to
come in listen for a long time come out
if you're entertaining that's really
good for ya you know I'm just very
passionate about new technology and I
always want to understand what's going
on and you know it continues yeah i
holla microsoft hololens right here you
know this is of the newest thing pretty
much best AR augmented reality
technology well until magically chips in
a couple months this is gonna be very
obsolete by the end of the year and then
you know it's funny cuz Facebook is
working on glasses the apples working on
glass the magic magic leap is working
classes snap G has just canceled theirs
but they're their glasses were a camera
with no display yes yeah but you're
gonna see a whole new range of glass
over the next three years but they're
too big and too ugly but they're amazing
when you wear oh they're incredible but
what this is a this one point two pounds
and it's too heavy for me to wear very
long but
when you when you wear it the aliens
come out of the wall it's pretty cool
and you thirty numbers pop up credit
card numbers top of the other thing is I
mean you see how many screens I have
around me and I can watch you know my
email Twitter Facebook all happening at
the same time yes and I can see this
sharply if I play the same screen and
hololens are in might be our machines
you know like an oculus rift right
HTC vive it's not sharp enough to read
read text and the optics won't be good
enough until later this year
HTC just announced at CES a new higher
resolution VR machine and we'll see if
it's good enough for text yes and you
need it so you need it to virtualize
your screens because I want to get rid
of these screens and have virtual
screens all right why pay for
electricity and pay for the physical
screens and you need place to store them
um you know I'm looking at I want more
screens around me and I don't have the
ability to put more physical screens so
I want glasses that virtualize the
screens and those are coming in the next
few years higher resolution we need
lighter weight we need group better
connectivity and wireless connectivity
for them so all these things are coming
5g is just literally gee I just saw
somebody talking and she's talking about
five g 5g brings 25 gigabits per second
down to your glasses right so we're
watching 200 megabits per second up on
this script on these screens right and
you and that's good enough for 4k video
wait until you have 25k you can have as
many screens around you as you want all
happening live that really matters for
things like self-driving cars as well
being able to send and receive that kind
of data flow and update update the
systems in real time when when you start
studying the world in 3d them
Dayna going up and down it's gonna be
pretty intense yes exactly
wait until we start thinking about
multi-party augmented reality I'm
actually a party augments yeah yeah let
me show you this a new thing came out
from Google yesterday let me see if I
can get it running fast motion still a
little dinosaur on your hand there you
go
so there's a little dinosaur on the hand
or a little cookie yeah okay well let's
bring it to the one that's live right
now which one is is it this one yeah
yeah so let me see if I can demo this
put a little thing in my hand and let me
see if I can get something a little bit
bigger there we go
so you can sort of see they're starting
to sense the physical world and they're
starting to put augmented stuff on top
of that physical on my hand and it's
pretty good it's it's not perfect yet
but it's pretty good this gives you a
sense of where things are going right we
have some other examples right into the
native photos
well native photos out but think about
wearing a pair of glasses a few years
and now I'm gonna augment things on top
of the real world there's going to be
you know new kinds of board games on
tables new kinds of things on top of
clouds yes new kinds of information
displays what you know everybody should
have this whenever they want everything
you know correction hey Google show me
Twitter right exactly and we have Google
at home here and we have Alexa now with
Amazon echo so you start talking to the
house exactly you're gonna be talking to
your glasses and asking for help with
things right is that the mood for calm
play my spot if I play with all that
good stuff okay Google
can you play ac/dc yeah and it
recognizes what you're doing and starts
playing a CD
play it yeah exactly just like that and
it yeah there we go
[Laughter]
let's turn all that off okay Google stop
thank you so so we're we're talking
about you know the history of Technology
now with exponential increases in
processing speeds and in making
equipment smaller word exploring space
with these things we're figuring out how
to map the functionalities of the brain
of the genome artificial intelligence
autonomous vehicles blockchain there's
own all these technologies they're
moving forward so you know you were
describing a bunch of augmented reality
futures where do you see all of this
going the singularity when jackasses and
that's scary right cuz that brings up
all the black American stuff right if
you haven't watched black mirror black
mirrors playing with all these new
technologies that are here and taking a
you know maybe 20-30 years into the
future and starting to think about the
dark side exactly right what happens
when you have Twitter all the time and
you what if if you could never turn this
on off if it's always there always and
you're always inside the script writers
here start playing with that kind of
world
well now you have to worry about your
gang raided and retweeted and right and
that causes all sorts of problems for
human beings so we weren't designed to
look in a screen like this all the time
we were designed to walk through a
forest and look for a lion trying to eat
us yeah which was a rare event right and
so you would pick the right berries so
ever well that's why your mind goes in a
high flow state and starts recording
things when when terror is happening
well this terrorizes me every day just
watch what you know our presidents done
and so it gets your mind really amped up
and the companies built these things to
take advantage of dopaminergic how our
minds work and get us addicted to this
yeah and it's it's a lottery it's so
addicting I keep looking at it instead
of looking at you and talking to you and
I'm
be doing in an interview it's it's a
lottery it's a it's a reward circuit
hijack of it's a constant pull in the
slot machine what's next what's next
what's next okay so we have this
dystopic we have the we have the black
mirror to show us what these the futures
look like dystopic lee and then how do
you envision us to best work together to
figure out how to make it more you
there's always with all technologies
there's a good and a bad right driving
everybody understands the good you know
we've been sold that and Corvette adds
it takes us places we get to go and to
work we get to go you know the score to
the store we get to go on a nice driving
along the coast if you are lucky enough
to live near the coast
but they kill 30,000 people a year right
well you don't think about the bad we
don't think about the cause we don't
think about the traffic the congestion
of these arteries and society we think
about the good right the stress levels
that come and all of these technologies
are gonna have a lot of good you know I
wanted this when I was in journalism
school I ran The Associated Press wired
machine and it was sort of like having
one of these feeds and I was able to see
the world in real time I remember the
day Oh Jay Simpson was found not guilty
that was six hundred stories filed in an
hour and I was able to see what was
happening in real time from all the
journalists who were there yes filing
stories and I wanted that I said why do
I have to why why as a news consumer do
I have to wait 18 hours to see the news
and the news paid for the next day
exactly and only get one or two stories
I want all 600 stories I want to see it
from all points of view and today I have
that this is this is my Associated Press
wired machine I get to see the world
from the point of view of investor's
point of view of founders point of view
of people in the crypto space point of
view of tech journalists right on and on
but this has downside to it you know
addiction and and false news now is a
problem because we're all spreading our
own news you know back in the newspaper
day we had a committee who decided what
everybody was going to read write an
editor many and it was hard to get
through that committee
yeah if you were a journalist you had to
argue your case that this story deserved
to be on the front page of the newspaper
and the committee the editor the editor
in chief assistant editors all got
together every day and said ok that
story deserves to be on the front page
where everybody's gonna read it today
we're all on the front page all the time
yes so if I post fake news and everybody
thinks it's real you you see it and you
have to deal with it and we're now
getting played by foreign governments to
sway right there building bot networks
that are putting information into this
stream that's really hard to figure out
what's right what's what's wrong and
even the news brands they've fired a lot
of their
fact checkers right back when I was a
kid they had a lot of money they had a
lot of business model the local
newspaper had 400 journalists working
for it now I have 40 Wow
right so the fact-checking systems that
built these brands are gone and so now
even the New York Times put stuff out
there that turns out not to be true
because it didn't have the same vetting
system it did 30 20 30 years ago so this
real problem for society how do we build
citizens that understand how to how to
pick the right thing from the wrong
thing from this data flow exactly and
it's a perfect segue into the point
so you described about technology being
having a lot of really good important
benefits that we need to maximize and
some things that are not so good and
let's lead into this one which is that
we have an overflow of data and it's
hard to find a signal from the noise so
you do things like this to find some
signal from the noise and it seems like
maybe doing something like TweetDeck and
organizing these lists by people that
you find most information aliy accurate
to be a good practice yeah and now the
companies are building AI pattern
recognizers to pick out the news for us
I told you about one I'm over here I see
trending items right yeah Bill Gurley is
trending because he just testified at
the Boober Google Court case they're
suing each other about the self-driving
car and he just testified so that the AI
put him into my view because it's sensed
that something was going on he was being
mentioned a lot right and so now these
systems can see things patterns and
bring them to our attention but those
patterns can have biases yeah because
we're biased we're we're biased and we
have taught these systems to be biased
so now you know who's checking the raw
data to see what's but what's biased and
what you know what's brought up here and
you and I both know that the popular
news is not necessarily the best news
right it's it's like you don't care that
much
about kim kardashian we rather hear
about what's going on with space
exploration or genetic game but I
guarantee you whatever Kim Kardashian
does trends right exactly because she
has a way of getting people interested
in what she's doing yes I've seen that
but I call that McDonald's right Micmac
news right popular news isn't
necessarily the broccoli that we need to
be today that's great
if you need only Big Macs every day for
a month you're gonna be sick right if
you don't need some broccoli and some
carrots and some you know vegetables and
lots funny the food analogy for content
is so funny yeah and I see it writing on
coca-cola's all day long this my
fructose corn syrup rather than taking a
little bit of project juice some and
we're getting it in a little dopamine
hits right we're not getting the long
book anymore you know very few of us are
reading books very few of us are reading
The New Yorker The Economist magazine a
long forms people call that slow news
right yes news you have to read for 20
minutes just to go through a single
article you don't get that word very
well yeah actually Twitter does bring it
to you if you set it up right I'm using
a an app called nuzzle and nuzzle shows
me the most popular long-form articles
Oh age that have been retweeted and I
find that reading this instead of this
makes me smarter helpful and with less
noise and less dopamine hit less
addiction no yeah because you don't get
the you don't get the dopamine it here
you get the dopamine because things are
moving things are moving things are
calling your name looks like the stock
market actually it is the stock market
the stock market's plunging right now
according to CNBC right these thoughts
are leading the planet uns market
volatility continues so so maybe as you
know we're talking a lot about social
we're talking a lot about the future of
Technology this is all amazing that we
can definitely go down this and how
to maximize human potential we can talk
about that we can maybe circle back to
it as well later but maybe let's let's
move on for now and see if we can chime
in on your your conversations with these
thousands of technologists and executive
overtime I backed way down but my best
friend runs innovation that JP Morgan
bank okay so we talked about crypto a
lot we talked about what what the future
of banking might be he's one of the
twelve guys who built the iPhones
amazing amazing technologists and and he
has an amazing network of his own across
the street here I mean this is nerd
heaven I don't know if you knew GoPro
literally started on one side of my
house and on the other side of my house
I can walk to Steve Jurvetson house
which is the guy who invested in Tesla
and SpaceX and hotmail and all sorts of
Skype well this is so compelling but if
I was in the Hollywood I'd have movie
stars and we prefer this that's why we
live here and we care about this and we
know what this means to driving the
world it's the broccoli and the carrots
instead of the coca-cola so we have
interesting conversations I mean I get
to hear about the struggles of Facebook
as a facebook executive lives lived down
the street and right across the street
is sa PSA I guy right yeah so we talk a
lot about you know how real is AI and
what's hype what's not and there's a lot
of hype but there's a lot of real and we
you know he's running supply chains say
P is how you order things right I used
to run sa P at NEC to were things to
keep track of our inventories and our
supply chain and what's going on right
so if you want to know how supply chains
are changing just talk to that guy right
and that's changing a lot because of
robotics and self-driving car soon AI
that recognizes patterns yes and
notifies you when things are happening
another friend is building an AI and he
finds human trafficking going on because
his AI goes to all the information in
the web think about that right he has an
AI personally I think that basically is
a Google now a good
of it maybe not at all but a lot of it
yeah and he it looks for patterns and it
finds patterns and it finds patterns
that don't fit like there's ads on
Craigslist for Toyota Priuses that were
built in 1979 the AI the AI says what
and kicks out a notification Newton says
I just found that Toyota Prius that was
not that was built in 1979 a for sale
but can't be possible because it found a
pattern of Toyota Prius is only here
built from 90s one right to today and so
there was an outlier and I kicked it
over to him he started looking at and
found out it was human trafficking yet
so the human traffickers were making up
fake ads to sell humans to other people
and there was a game you know there was
a code that if you see a 1979 Prius or
something like that you would find the
human abajo right you would know how
much she is what race she is all based
on code in the ad is this part of what
Ashley Kutcher's up to as well Ashtyn
probably is working with this guy made
it really should meet yeah he's working
with the FBI now and stuff like that but
that gives you an idea of the pattern
recognition capability of computers I
can't see patterns like humans just we
have to invest way too much time to find
this and in fact the FBI didn't know
that this was going on so he recognized
something new happening in society based
on the information on the public
Internet
let's talk about self-driving cars I
just wanted to see those patterns are
that that's insanely important if you
find outliers like that that's a
notification do some research those a
little 0.1% urge that are kind of
straggling in these different areas and
to identify them and see what's going on
they could also be kind of the Eureka
moments for civilization like why are
these people also doing this thing that
could be different than what everyone
else is doing that could actually be
very beneficial that the same
information is being used to sell sell
and buy stocks right Foursquare knows
knows how well the iPhone sold before
Apple discloses it because it knows how
many people walked into the store the
day the the limper sale
so now Foursquare has the data
to tell investors sell your stock
nobody's fine I'll or five more Apple
stock because every Apple sales are
higher than we've expected right because
more people are walking in the store
that we expected stuff like that he has
this the same guy he's doing human
trafficking he his thing kicks out docks
to buy it's been trained to look for
stocks to buy based on patterns do you
are the most person I've ever spoken to
about Twitter ology you are so amazingly
connected into the teks fear which
incredible I love your geek about this
it's amazing which you eat before the
cameras turned on you you asked me about
stratification of human beings doesn't
owning an AI like that give you a lot of
power absolutely and a lot of potential
wealth and and just a better life a
better life because it tells you like
hey a new restaurant opened up today
that a famous chef is opening up locally
I saw that on Facebook and guess what a
michelin-rated Reza
opened a little tiny restaurant here in
half an Bay and and if you're watching
the news you would see it if you have an
ain't I telling what a live for Apple
stock you can know about what's gonna be
happening to had certain companies
because of you parsing binding signal in
a lot of noise I'd dinner with a CEO of
an oil refinery in Canada in Eastern
Canada and he says that the financial
analysts have paid for satellites to be
over his refinery with a sensor looking
at heat and if his refinery goes offline
for any reason yeah it turns cool
exactly or it turns really hot because
it just blew up either event they the
oil markets need to know and and every
second you know means millions of
dollars because you can sell stock is
sell prices before the oil price changes
right or when Roberts maybe texting
somebody and saying hey sorry I was on
my email the last two hours but really
you were taking a run or
eating at a restaurant or something and
then Google is able to be like no he
wasn't sending emails for two hours and
no there's all this kind of stuff ai if
you look maybe we go into a little bit
of the wealth stratification well it's
this is where it's going right the
wealthy you're gonna have an AI right
they're gonna invest in having their own
version of what my friend has to show
them new patterns in life
make sure you know or they're gonna pay
him to run their AI and let them know
when they should sell their investments
when you know when they should move you
know because I'll send the world
climates changing and they can see that
before other people or healthcare
biometric information right and they're
getting access to the latest science so
I went out of South Africa and I met
with Cheerilee Calder she's an eye
doctor down in South Africa she works
with professional athletes and she hats
their brains think of a violin back in
their branch she's a professional
athlete herself she found a way to hack
her brain make her performance better
her perception system better and she
built a computer program to do that for
athletes now you can do it too it's $100
a month yeah she took the worst rider on
the South African cycling team in terms
of falls per race he kept falling
because he had a perception problem in
the peloton and he used her app for 10
minutes a day for six months he's best
on the team today so start thinking
about you know how do you become I have
to wear glasses what if I could use her
program and not have to wear glasses
doesn't that make my life better or even
if I have to wear glasses if I can see a
ball coming to me a little bit better
maybe I can play baseball with my kid or
teach my kid how to play baseball now
you know the difference between a gold
medal and a SIL ah here's a story I met
the guy who invented the backward
Highjump dick Fosbury right and he told
me the difference between gold and
silver that year was 2 centimeters
eight point three feet in the air right
that was and by winning the gold you get
your name on the frickin sport everybody
calls it the Fosbury flop the number two
guy I don't know the guys guys name
right so so it in terms of the
difference between winning silver and
cold is very small number so if you get
a eye doctor who teaches you how to see
things better
oh you're winning colds and you're
winning you know you're changing sport
you're Stephen Curry didn't and I know
Stephen Curry is using techniques like
hers to improve his perception system so
he can see that basket and see the ball
way better than his teammates can yeah
because he found a way to pack his brain
so this is what rich people are - yes
rich people know about this because
their kids go to Stanford right yes and
Stanford puts you in touch with people
like this I met I met a guy who's poor
and his son is gonna be a world-class
soccer player he didn't know about this
exactly so I said this is why you need
to get your kid to go to Stanford or
Carnegie Mellon or someplace with really
smart people or Illinois University or
go Waterloo University or a good
university that has people like this who
are interested in pushing him in
performance back exactly so this gets
back to Ted tack don't you want your kid
just drive a self-driving car I do cuz
they will kill a lot less yeah they'll
have a downside to him you know they
might kill him he might be the
unfortunate one you know a Tesla re
killed somebody after 1.3 million miles
he was killed people after nine hundred
thousand miles so already the Tesla
killed fewer people with their sensors
Venice than a human driven car Mercedes
told me the same thing that the bumpers
with a sensor in them they sell fifteen
percent your bumpers with just a
front-facing radar sensor not full
self-driving where it turns the steering
wheel and stuff it just warns you if
you're about to hit something and it
enables a radar assisted cruise control
stuff like that
but it warns you if you're about to hit
something so it wakes you up 15% less
bumper sales that means fewer deaths
just with a pre consents ur so where's
the Ralph Nader of this generation
saying why aren't these car companies
putting this sensor in all of them we we
used to have this argument about seat
belts right they only put them in seat
belts and luxury cars because that was
an expensive thing at the time in the
sixties then Ralph Nader said that
should be an all car I'm arguing it
should be an all cars Oliver it's
Janelle that system yes technology yes
and I want self-driving cars for
everybody yes but that's I'm still
working for everybody better health care
for everybody better signal from the
noise but an AI for everybody so let's
let's talk rich people have all this
yeah correct correct so so now I have
verification exactly so let's go so you
are surrounding yourself with very
brilliant people you live in an area
that has lots of billion people I do too
but you even more so here I live in the
city I'm you living have a very
beautiful area lots of smart people like
you were saying there's access to all
these different kind of technologies
that enhance their life in many
different ways and maybe somebody in
Oklahoma doesn't have that or maybe
somebody in Africa or Southeast Asia as
yet to have that or Latin America
somewhere else maybe there are things in
Hong Kong and Tokyo that people here
don't have it cetera so my question is
this then let's talk about
stratification of their stuff poor
people by the way yes Iraq people in
those areas sometimes live more happy
and more fulfilled lives with less
things why is why I'm an alcoholic
I go to Alcoholics Anonymous and I'm in
touch with the bottom half world people
who killed people
people have raped people people who
[ __ ] up their lives gotten fired pate
ate DUIs yeah got arrested right spent
time in jail people you don't generally
like to hang yes there they found a way
to be happy yes because they believe in
God there's something about it I used to
be a really anti-god person
there's something about our human mind
when we believe in say how at higher
power you don't even have to call it God
when you believe you're part of a system
and there's something bigger than you
obvious in your happiness level goes up
yeah number two if you pray your
happiness level goes up if you meditate
your happiness someone goes up so if you
learn how to breathe
deeply and calm your brain down right
I'll sudden your thinking a little bit
better there was just a study I read on
Twitter
25% smarter people who meditated
yeah which is weird yeah but that's you
know not necessarily the rich people
don't always get there right because the
rich people are focused on acquiring
things buying things or crushing things
and things they don't quite get the
spirituality needed to be happy right
being social that makes you happier not
being on alcohol or drugs thank you
laughter right so all the sudden you can
learn something from the floor poor
people in the world because they have
the ability to change and change rapidly
because they have to to survive and
certainly if you've been arrested eight
times you better change or you're gonna
spend the rest of your life in jail
right and that's not gonna be fun and
your your if you're an alcoholic or a
drug addict you're facing huge
consequences and we need to figure this
out because we're killing forty thousand
people a year on opiates 53,000 yeah I
heard the latest number that's a lot
that's a lot yeah and yeah this is
slowly helping with that slowly helping
but VR now let's talk about so yeah we
are at the University of Washington
found that VR is better at during
physical pain on burn victims then
opiates are that's amazing so why are we
giving all of our kids opiates to get
over pain we should be giving them VR
and say play a game that's
counterintuitive most people don't don't
understand how that were and there's old
money in those industries that's there's
a lot of money making on opiates and a
lot of money on keeping people addicted
and this isn't stuff that politicians
talk about a lot of times right and
that's why we have an opiate problem and
it's expensive to buy VR right now so
and same thing with self-driving car
having a self-driving car today
you know Tesla first of all you have to
spend about a sixty thousand dollars to
get a Tesla with seven cameras on it
that's for a fairly wealthy person yeah
that's not for your Toyota crowd yet
it's getting closer yeah I can see how
it's gonna get there but not yet yeah so
these things cost a lot of money and we
need the rich people to say hey it's
important for these kinds of things to
get to everybody because it won't
improve everybody's lives including the
rich person okay now here's my question
because I guarantee you the rich guy
Bill Gates or you know or whoever is you
know rich their lives are better if
their friends and their families friends
aren't dying from opiates or [ __ ] up
their family life and screwing up their
companies because who's dying it's their
workers you know but this seems to be a
and their community will that have a
good amount of money once you gain some
money you gain a lot of problems so now
we were just talking about lower lower
socioeconomic status people having
somehow I'm more happiness and more
fulfillment in lives at times without
all of this crazy amounts of Technology
so maybe we yeah cuz steering if this
doesn't make it happy this'll make you
insane so I've studied both sides
insanity and the sanity side so okay so
let's let's try and find the sanity
within the side that's the most
connected technology and the sandy
that's the least connected to technology
and figure out the good in those and
then bring them together because right
now we have lower socioeconomic places
in the world that don't have electricity
or that don't have running water they
don't have the basic necessities but for
some reason they are still enjoying life
more than somebody that has to sit in
traffic for two hours a day that has to
buck away at a computer keyboard at a
job that they don't really like just to
pay rent to live in a place that they
don't really want its cetera because we
were designed to walk through forests
and catch a fish once oh wow or catch an
animal eat it or grow some vegetables to
need it and have a slow pace of life
we need to learn something from them how
do you get you know this why am i I
didn't I didn't understand the role of
vacations before I was forced to take
one right and now I understand [ __ ]
those people those people have an answer
to a lot of the unhappiness that we feel
I know that leads to a lot of bad
behavior you know and we can go to that
yeah so that we can learn something from
from why our human brains are happier in
some situations and how to bring it to
this kind of world and how to how to
make sure you moderate if you have to
stare at a screen like this how do you
get away from it and do some exercise do
some meditation do some pray a little
bit right we need a book do you think
that we need to bring this technology to
everyone across the world because right
now maybe only the wealthy could afford
autonomous vehicles in the AIS and the
gene editing and all that stuff but soon
I think some my level my poor level and
then even sooner it'll come to that
people that are we poor than even I am
and so my tears I think it does is it
actually important yeah for those yeah
it is first so you think that all seven
and a half potentially also I don't have
billion people need to be provided with
this of these maximising technology I
don't want to say everybody needs to
have a para AI class okay um we have a
bigger problem human beings at some
point in the near future aren't going to
start agreeing that we have a climate
problem right I'm watching the ocean I
live right by the ocean there's fewer
pelicans going by my window every year
the water is getting warmer the climate
is changing we know this we can watch it
with satellites there's now a start-up
that has a satellite satellite pictures
of the entire world every 15 minutes so
we can watch the news and the scientists
know the data and I'm on the side of we
have a problem and we have a major
problem on the side of communicating the
science right so how do we get everybody
on the right side of stopping burning
carbon figuring out how to grow trees
and there was a report I saw yesterday
that we've already passed the point of
preed saving there
we need to figure out how to scrub
carbon out of there out of the air
faster and I see this is gonna be
another problem everybody knows about
global the water level raising and we
could see it the erosion here on the
coast that's starting to happen that the
Ritz in 40 years is gonna be gone and
they say that the rate of erosion is
faster than they predicted when they
built the Ritz
ten years ago right so we can see the
water level going up I don't think
that's going to be the biggest problem
that's a huge problem for cities like
Miami New Orleans San Francisco New York
Shanghai
cities that are close to ocean water
going up it's a huge problem kind of
caused a lot of damage and gonna have to
figure out how to deal with that so we
need these goal consensus but I think
there's a bigger problem at the same
time that we're heating up the ocean
we're also acidifying it exactly and
we're putting a lot of [ __ ] into the
ocean plastics and stuff like that we're
seeing a lot of die-off of things
you're seeing the Great Barrier Reef in
Australia for instance going dad yep
that's a warning sign that soon the
ocean isn't gonna be able to support the
food needs of many many people yeah you
talk about all the different levels of
people from the rich guy who's eating
sushi and Tokyo to the poorest of the
poor is pulling a fish out of the ocean
they're the same yeah there's a lot of
people who get their nutrients off the
sea laughs and soon I mean within the
next to so many decades I'd have to look
at the actual rate soon we're not gonna
be able to support human life off the
oceans so we're gonna have to change our
food source clean me all this good stuff
and that's why I spent some time with an
ambassador who's investing in Memphis
meats and stuff like that because they
see this as a trend that soon we're
gonna need to make meat out of vegetable
vegetable oil vegetable matter vegetable
protein proteins because we're not gonna
be able yeah but I think we're even
gonna have to go further we're gonna
have to go to totally vegetable based
food well you talked to a red-blooded
American about eat it eating only
vegetables they are like you mean I
gotta give up my steak you know no way
right so now we have a big problem how
do we get people to change goes back to
Alcoholics Anonymous you know you can
keep getting DUIs mister drunk do you
want to change and not [ __ ] up your life
anymore
you gotta start changing yeah and you
got to start learning to change truck
drivers 1.3 million truck drivers in
America you're not gonna have a job in
20 years let's just be honest about
exactly so how do we change you how do
we get you into something new we can do
it we have the best technology of
Education we've ever had we can teach
somebody how to fix them
caterpillar million-dollar tractor with
these things and while we already are
we're even using this stuff on football
it's at Stanford University there was a
company called Stryver that started by
using VR so that the quarterback could
visualize his plays better and learn
faster
and do play as better in it they have
the stats the rich people know the stats
improves your life this stuff improves
your life it's $3,000 though right and
so a truck driver is like $3,000 I don't
want to do that too dorky and there what
are you gonna do you know I'm still
driving the truck and there's no solid
educational curriculum for them to
actually train off of truck driving into
a new technology no so we need the rich
people start talking about that instead
of talking about you know guaranteed
minimum income that ain't gonna be the
answer cuz that's socialism and
communism really don't like what is your
answer then if you bi can't sustain the
post work on you we need to get to a
road where we get cheap augmented
reality glasses that's coming in the
next three to five years that's coming
but why is that your because that
teaches you new things very quickly you
want to learn how to cook right now I'm
having to learn how to run a crock
frustrating visa [ __ ] though you yeah we
should take it take these cameras down
the kitchen and show you the UI the UI
on a crock pot is like ludicrous my
friend Andy made fun of it it's like why
is the why is the minus sign right next
to the power you know there it's really
hard to figure out it's hard to figure
out for somebody who's used to you know
figuring out where your [ __ ] you could
have augmented reality in the kitchen
teaching you how to do stuff right and
teach you how to cook can teach you how
to weld
if you hey watch this watch this is fun
okay Google can you show me how to weld
on YouTube it has an answer
said sure
and
it's trying to find an answer and watch
the whole thing in augmented reality in
front of you on how to well yeah and
there's how to code so you're saying
that augmented reality is democratizing
that as quickly as possible
is the best way to get people to learn
more efficacious mercedes-benz are
raised using AR for the firefighters who
are gonna show up on your wreck so let's
say you're a number saves beds you're in
a bad wreck
the firefighters get there and they have
to cut apart your car to save your life
they have a few minutes to do this
because you're dying they use augmented
reality on the phone that shows where to
cut the car part without causing a fire
and it's for 30 car for all of the cars
for the last 30 years already and for 30
different languages already don't they
built it because they know it saves
lives and it's better to teach people
how to do that and looking through a
book of paper trying to figure out is
this car that car because it's okay so
what I'm hearing right now is that
because perception was one of the most
important evolutionary advances and then
because we use it to see so much of what
we interact with every single day and
how we experience the universe is
through these eyes but mostly yep then
it makes most sense to figure out how to
quickly democratize augmenting our
perception systems to better learn yeah
and engage and play and dance through
this world and save lives and reduce
suffering that make our lives better too
right yeah interesting that augmented
reality you know it was never such a
clear answer from you like it is now
yeah I reflect over in Munich told me
that's why I'm visit a few months ago
they're working on systems to get rid of
manuals in the car and and furniture
right you go to Ikea why do you why do
you need to read a manual but even with
pictures it's hard
use your phone aiming at things it says
put that there
it's really easy we learn very fast
visually if we're shown stuff and you
got back - what would the politicians do
in the rich people do um I don't believe
that guaranteed minimum income is gonna
be sellable to many people absolutely
absolutely
maybe 50 years from now that'll be an
answer but right now people are still
coming off the cold war of thinking and
still coming out of you know many of the
rich people built their wealth by
working their asses off and having a
capitalist system right and they
understand that it's more efficient for
its society than a communist system
absolutely
in general China is starting to mess
with our minds because they're playing
with a different model and but Americans
aren't ready for that Chinese system
China I can tell you to move and get out
of your house today yeah and you can't
do anything about here in America we're
not even close to thank you because they
want to build us so he or something I
don't believe we're gonna be able to
sell either to the rich people or even
the poor people a socialism or communism
easily but my dad took us out of coal
mining my dad was the first one to go to
college in our family and he took us out
of coal mining to where I'm seeing the
first guy to see Siri in one generation
right and he did that with the GI Bill
so I think we need a new GI Bill
we need a GI Bill where you mister truck
driver you know sorry you're not gonna
have a job
machine replaced your job but we're
gonna give you a fair shot at the new
American dream right new American dream
you get four years we're gonna give you
some glasses and maybe some human
instruction go to college some of the
time go learn something new we're gonna
test you on what you're good at but you
know what you can do with your fingers
and your hands and your eyes
the eye doctor I was talking about the
purchase she does is test you to see how
bad your eyes aren't and where you have
weaknesses right so she knows can you
play ball can you build something can
you weld something can you lift
something right so we can do some tests
like that let's see where you you know
are you personable you have to put in a
Starbucks I can teach you with augmented
reality how to make a latte right now
I'll say you have a job and you're part
of society and that's a key to to
society to us we need a mission in life
we need to feel like we're part of
society if you just give us a guaranteed
minimum income and even let me live the
same life I'm not going to be very happy
because I'm not I don't have a mission
in life I don't have something to do I
don't feel like I have an identity
anymore and you ripped away my identity
that I built three years thirty years
back right fascinating so let me get a
quick summary of this is that you be I
potentially won't work out because it's
more difficult for people to become self
actualized by themselves when they're
just getting a paycheck in the mail
versus if we give them an democratized
augmented reality for everybody and get
them trained on things that they will
slowly pick up something that they
actually like doing every single day
then we can maybe retain more of the
capitalistic model they can find more
creative work exactly etcetera yeah yeah
even if it's something stupid you know
it's seemingly stupid if he told me 20
years ago that people know that ten
sixty thousand people would go in the
middle of the desert and burn millions
of dollars were at the art and have a
party I would have been like right in
the desert and and some of the best
artists were home treatment you know and
why would you have a party in the middle
of the deserts in the desert right
[ __ ] I mean go back a hundred years
and say why would we build Las Vegas
right so maybe we need more burning
man's and we need those are gonna be
some of the creative jobs is create
entertainment for people but it's not
gonna be once a year it's gonna be every
freaking day
and yeah and all around the world right
now sudden you got millions of people
doing art and maybe it's not how do they
pay for that well rich people seem like
they're very willing to pay a lot of
people to love the stuff that they've
earned that or build the stuff that
they've burned down that Burning Man
right so maybe okay maybe there's a
pattern here I would as a rich person
maybe that's a little bit better than a
guaranteed minimum income where you just
create a welfare class of people sitting
around their necks right at least you
get a good party out of it right a
little bit more sellable than just
sitting around doing nothing right and
you start looking at what else you need
to do in society now the global warming
is heating out the ocean right the ocean
what happens to water when it heats up
it kicks off more starts so we're gonna
have more houses were blown away Richard
Branson lost his [ __ ] house on his
island and he's a billionaire right so
even he was touched by global warming
and so you get Houston lost 10,000 homes
New Orleans lost lots of home I was in
the Ninth Ward and saw the effect of a
flood right yeah a lot of bad homes they
need to be rebuilt so now you're
building armies or robots or new kinds
of homes I friend of mine just sent me a
home that can build itself right and
assemble itself off of a truck so now
you're you have armies of people
building armies of homes to rebuild
cities that are blown away by storms
right and give people something homes to
live in right we just had a huge fire up
here that burned 5,000 6,000 homes why
aren't those homes already rebuilt why
are we arguing about you know with
insurance companies and you know all the
permitting processes and all that it's
gonna take two three four years to
rebuild those homes why can't we have a
army of robots that rebuild instantly
and rebuild them and get people back in
their homes it's stupid to me it's like
we don't think about this stuff very
well I'd rather do that than have a
guaranteed minimal income because that
gives people jobs and gives people
better way of life less suffering in the
world and when if you could do that for
NAPA you can do that for Africa or
wherever the need is right Syria why
yeah mr. Trump you don't want to bring
the Syrian refugees here let's build
them [ __ ] homes so they can live you
know let's solve this problem you know
so they can live where they want to live
which is in their home they don't want
to come in or they're coming here
because they don't have a home anymore
somebody blew it up and it's causing
problem in their neighborhood people
don't want to leave their home if they
have a home so let's fix this problem
yeah but this very affordable robotic
but we have a whole military-industrial
complex that my dad was part of that
likes to blow [ __ ] up because there's
millions of dollars right the Israelis
know this when a missile comes from
Palestine over the computers decide
whether they're gonna blow up the
missile or not because it costs half a
million dollars to blow up the missile
you know if it lands on a field they're
gonna let it land if it lands if it's
gonna land on a house they blow it up
yeah with the yard down that's why it's
so many brilliant people come out of
Israel because they're thinking about
that how do you not blow up money but
can we get along I don't know but can we
build homes yeah I think that's sellable
to people I think that I think people on
the Trump side of that fence can get
into that yeah mr. Trump you want to
build a wall let's build a wall around
our cities protect our city from the
water that's gonna have come you know
I'd be it for that you want to build a
wall to keep is that it make rinse out
well let's do something else
figure that figure out why they're
coming here fix that problem yeah
they're coming here because there's a
economic reality here
half a computer started down the street
two kids sitting korat yeah
built the wealthiest company in the
world in 30 years right that's the
opportunity of being an American so
let's bring on a mirror and let's bring
that opportunity everybody around the
world
you're a poverty I realize that an
American only thing that's gone
so the world starting to wake up but
wait we got a ways to go
technology is part of the solution it's
a part of the problem yeah we're gonna
need a new Silicon Valley attitude and
the CEOs haven't figured that out yet
what Benioff has but everybody else
so this is a
very beautiful way to phrase kind of the
state of things I think so I think when
you speak of robots going in building
homes in places for very cheap that's a
very good idea to people in those places
that way they want to live I think when
you talk about augmented reality rather
than universal basic income I think
that's very interesting I'm still
slightly skeptical about well and a GI
Bill you need four years to take a truck
driver off a truck driving and give him
a shot at doing something else so that
has some value I need to be quite that
long because we see all the kids going
through like hack reactor things like
might not be little camps but it
certainly was with augmented reality
glasses I can see a world where I could
train somebody to work at a Starbucks
tonight because it shows you on top of
the cups and it's senses where
everything is not something that we want
to train them to do that's all that's a
legit job come on
that's another robot I worked a job like
that come on it's a very it's a job
that's heading towards being roboticized
maybe someday but not today I think
within the same amount of time that
truck driver so there's no point to
train people to do it
my point is I if I had augmented reality
glasses on your face you can learn
anything you need to know in real time
on top of the machine
so if there is a job for a couple more
weeks you could have a job for a couple
more weeks and then we could switch you
somewhere else your plumbers not your
body size but I could teach you how to
do plumbing if I had one could get good
at interdisciplinary learning on top of
augmenting yeah okay yeah yeah oh yeah
I've been I've been asking people geez
Amazon Amazon of course have you used
the camera yeah yeah let's see it
alright let's let's do like the tires so
it's a hidden it's there but nobody
knows what it does there's a little
camera right here on there Amazon right
let's get let's get but there we go but
let me find something that might be good
or as to well let's look at this camera
for instance let's look at this one cuz
I lied on and you just turn on the
camera
and it starts scanning it and starts
figuring out brand names and things and
it it didn't recognize that camera
because that's not trained yet in the AI
that's a tough one because but let's try
your suit
sure let's start it up it starts looking
at your suit instantly men's suits pops
men's blazers and shows me all the
pictures look at those look at this
right
so so put it on the middle want to put
it on the middle cam this one this one
yeah yeah I'll take it alright so men's
suits I've been asking people in San
Francisco do you play with us literally
nobody has played with that feature yeah
and and therefore literally nobody has
really tried it on a variety of things
yeah and literally nobody is thinking
about what that means in five or ten
years cuz you're gonna have little
cameras on your glasses but you just
look at something and you say oh I like
that suit mobster the mini pops out and
starts telling you about it but the same
camera technology will know everything
about your world and will know if you're
working in Starbucks where the your cups
are where your coffee things are where
the controls are on the machine and I'll
tell yours it'll tell you how to do that
yes you're a cheap robot and I don't
think every job is gonna be robotisized
that pass because right now to build a
humanoid robot like they have you know
back in Boston that we've seen on
YouTube that's hundreds of thousands of
dollars yeah but I would you know pay
acts and there's so many other there's
so many other companies going into the
tea and coffee robot is I think that one
is down is a clear example of very soon
just like autonomous vehicles I get it
but there's still a lot of jobs that are
gonna be around for a while yeah maybe
not decades
I really would think that technology is
important to play with this go to the
Amazon app on your phone click the
camera button in the search bar and
start scanning things in your house that
trying to see if it recognizes them and
just get used to that sort of technology
because that will be on your I've meant
to reality glass looking at the world
around you now just to go back one one
one quick point about the creativity
within the educational curriculum on
augmented reality I'm not sold on
everybody that gets out of their job
gets automated to be able to be
retrained through education through
augmented reality because I'm not quite
sure that everyone is going to be able
to
you do some sort of a creative endeavor
with maybe out of a thousand people how
many can 200 300 500 even 500 that's
worth saving that's amazing that's
amazing
the other 500 you got to figure out
something else something else and we
should figure out what that is but if we
can cover 50% with this amazing let's
get people trained let's get them
China's teaching kids this way they know
they don't have enough teachers to teach
the kids the kids are growing at a
higher rate than the teacher Pulis so
they're using VR and other techniques to
teach their kids and spread the
knowledge of the teacher to markets yes
you know the teacher unions resists this
kind of thinking because it keeps them
in a job correct but most of us can
learn by watching a TED video yeah a lot
of us do and so why can't admit in
reality teach a lot of kids now I have a
special needs there their character
earlier I have a special-needs kid I
have an autistic child who's not gonna
be able to learn very easily although I
admit reality's gonna play a huge role
in his life and helping him be a
productive member of society because his
glasses will teach him and remind him of
things well all sorts of emotions you
know look in people's eyes you know and
but even you know teaching him how to
tie his shoes and do things around the
house and remind him of what he needs to
do right and that will make him more
productive um yeah you know even if it's
500 people 500 truck drivers it's that's
a huge way to solving the problem yeah
yeah I can't solve all the world's
problems but if I could solve 54 I'll be
here if I could solve 50 for sales
profits you know so all of us have to
figure out how does how to get more and
more people and into the new world now
there are lots of jobs I visited a
company in Illinois called Agri Bowl and
they grow virtual crops
that's a weird job the job could not
exist four years ago they have a hundred
and I think they have now a couple
hundred it's not your simulation
of crops yeah because guess what we have
new yes we have new technologies and
farming right we have a satellite over
your field didn't understand your
nitrate levels and your water levels and
stuff like that
you have sensors on the field now 3m
said within the next five to ten years
you're gonna have 50 sensors per acre so
you have internet things devices in your
field and certainly you get them on your
combines now your combines cost a
million dollars when you buy a new
combine and it has sensors sensing the
nitrate levels of the ground and all
sorts of stuff and you have government
data feeds from the price of corn to
price whatever their system takes all
that data analyzes it in a few seconds
grows a virtual crop which predicts how
your crop will do your real crop and
sells the data back to the farmer it's a
very interesting company it's right
underneath John Deere's R&D lab in
Illinois right hundreds of people have a
job today that couldn't exist four years
ago and there's gonna be a lot more jobs
like that those are highly trained jobs
they're computer scientists the ADA
scientists people understand how to see
patterns and things right
how to take data off of an Internet of
Things device and do something in code
with it I those are highly trained
people so the truck driver to that kind
of job gonna be hard yeah it's gonna be
hard yes so I'm not gonna try to take
the truck driver to that kind of job I'm
gonna try to take the truck driver to
doing an uber job for doing some other
kind of job yeah
cutting lawns I just saw three guys
cutting their line out here right those
are little jobs and and there are really
jobs in a society if if I didn't have
somebody cutting my lon I'd have to do
it instead of looking at Twitter haha
just make me less efficient and wiki and
Twitter then I am right so
[Music]
ah where am I going with all that I got
you you can do a lot and there's some
real magical technology there's
technology that has dark down side and
where I do that out because these things
are listening to us at some level we I
know they're not really listening to us
you know but they're listening ok Google
2+2
the answer is four right so it's
listening it's always there and it's
watching our patterns it knows where I
am
yeah there's a lot of a lot of privacy
we gave up to get a system like this but
once you give it up you get really
magical stuff you think that with
privacy and I'm all for signing up for
you 50% of people getting work through
education it's reality amazing idea I
love it
do you think that with privacy that it's
better for us to all just completely
give up access to everything in term in
the light of benevolent people trying to
parse that you can't have my bank
information so I do want that private
you can't have my password keys right
that's password keys banking information
we argue about this in alcoholics
Anonymous I'm not even supposed to tell
you that I'm in alcoholics Anonymous
it's part of anonymous as part of the
word of it and we have an argument if
that's cool now you know it does my
thing it's our Bible which is called the
big book doesn't talk about the internet
does not not it does talk about
anonymity and press radio and films and
it's there for a principle which is
keeping people so far if they think
they're gonna be outed by coming to an
AAA meeting they're less likely to get
sober there's a principle there Yeah
right and that's why they chose that
structure because they know more people
get sober if their boss doesn't find out
about it or their co-workers aren't
giving them [ __ ] about their addiction
or what not right me I'm just out I
don't care about me but I am very clear
on that say some fool because I
understand why that rule was placed or
that guideline that principle was placed
and its role in human minds and how
helping people change
there's stuff like that that I think
people are gonna want to keep out
healthcare is still healthcare is a good
one to give away it is if you think like
that and then our healthcare whether
they can take putting about you do you
want your sexually transmitted disease
to get to you or did you want them to
know that you might die early because of
some sir genetic problems or that you're
gonna be in the hospital or cause like
Microsoft is a self-insured company so
if I hire you and I know you're gonna be
a cancer patient
I just cost the company money right so
you might not want the hiring agents
that Microsoft to know that you have
cancer right
so there's a lot of stuff stuff like
that and there's a lot of things like if
you're going through a gender reassess
people get killed for that still in
America so you don't want that to be
that's discussed right you might not
there's a whole range of things that are
dangerous to share exactly and I I'm not
about sharing those kinds of things okay
but so but but these systems do share
that kind of information passwords
no-goes but yeah but these systems are
totally working together to try and find
the really good David I couldn't figure
out your password by listen if I could
listen to you tapping Keys I'm pretty
sure that the depresses went out your
password so now we have we start going
down the black we're out where we're
gonna have to figure figure out how to
protect people from consequences I think
it's the right conversation to have
it's not about privacy so much although
consequences is your my identity skiing
stolen well that's why I don't want to
give you my password to my bank is I
know you or somebody load somebody out
there upon my money right so that's why
we don't want to keep those very private
and why we want to have different
passwords for every website we go to
because if you figure out how to hack my
gmail so you're getting into my bank
right if I use the same password so if
we start thinking about that so there's
security and privacy and constant
consequences it's a real one but I I can
how do we keep people free of
consequences of you know going to a
doctor and putting on a medical device
that's studying their body or putting
their genome into the system I
I'll send I know everything about you
you know and and if I can put a brief I
wore a bracelet at the next web when I
was onstage that I was made by in Pataca
and it has sensors that study my
electrical system and it's used with
stroke victims now and
seizure victims and he could tell how
nervous I was on stage in real time
that's cool and he showed the audience
how nervous I was and then we started
talking about the red-light district and
my nervous system spiked yeah yeah so
now he's in my head a little bit and
some day I can it slow I can see wearing
some sensors and the understanding how
you think think about that now I can
understand if you're a terrorist did you
did you see where you and where an eg
and then when you're thinking about
pressing the red button and it lights up
red so it so it's mapping your yeah I'm
sure before you actually get there yeah
yeah yeah
so if I can study your brain at that
level I know how you think I and I know
where y'all your character defects are I
know what I likely you are to be another
or I know how likely you are to be a
murderer or a rapist or anything right
yeah that's all fear and now I can start
working with you to improve but there's
the downside this is good that was good
on privacy let's go let's go let's do a
couple speed round things set up to end
here let's do a speed round with
geopolitics what do you think about the
United States and China kind of racing
for AI racing for genetic engineering
racing cars all this kind of stuff be
collaborating more how should we be
working on they're gonna crush us they
have 800 million Internet users they're
Internet users are in cities closer
together that they are they have more
chaos in the street they have more
people to study BAM more users they have
people everybody is on is being
surveilled yeah right they don't care
about surveillance their government has
forced the citizenry there that put up
with it they are using it their phone
for payments today most Americans still
don't do that yeah so they are more
advanced on they're used to mobile
phones and technology they're more
likely to use VR than they are because
they're in smaller homes where you want
to scape from your family and you're
very willing to put something on your
face escape
and on and on
and the government is very willing to be
spend people's lives in in response to
government initiatives I saw I was there
in 95 but in Shanghai and they took me
up in the TV tower and they had just
plowed hundreds of acres ie they had
just moved a lot of people somewhere
else and they had just raised destroyed
that part of town he said that's where
our Wall Street's gonna exactly and
today that Wall Street is built when you
go there all the tallest buildings in
the world there are many of the tallest
buildings and welder they're right next
to the TV tower you looking down on the
TV tower pearl tower the government is
very willing to make action like that
and mess with their citizenry because
they and the system it puts up with it
because they recognize they're getting
richer because they're moving faster
than we are they are taking more risks
and they're doing things they build
buildings and days months or years and
fixing an escalator in six months and so
they are running ahead and they're
running ahead about engineering and the
same thing opens it's the same thing
there but they're taking the risk on
behalf of all of civilization they're
not even taking the risk on just behalf
of them they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it and they're gonna
discover all sorts of new things and
they may kill us in the frosting to kill
us cuz they're just a self interested in
in stayin alive as we are they're gonna
discover new ways to make people's lives
better because they're gonna see
patterns that we don't see they're
self-driving car the lady runs alibaba's
self-driving car team says we're behind
America we know that Google's been doing
self-driving car since the 90s right I
saw Stanford's team win the DARPA
challenge
but they have way more chaos in the
street and these systems I mean I took
the Tesla yesterday for a drive and let
it out of Drive
there's no [ __ ] chaos on my little
Street out here two lane road you might
think there is the tracks coming towards
you and stuff like that but in China
there's 500 people thousand people on
the street and walking around and
there's people I saw two motorcycles
going the wrong way there's so much
chaos that the system will have to learn
to deal with so their system is going to
learn faster faster faster faster faster
and gonna up pass ours in terms of
instance per hundred thousand miles and
their systems are gonna be better in 20
years
so you think China's leading the 21st
century yeah I think I think there they
are
I think Silicon Valley right now it's
still Silicon Valley I mean Google still
Apple still here but Facebook Twitter
but the centricity you can feel it's
moving over to Beijing right WeChat
billion people using it right all the
system there's new game it's the
surveillance on everybody everybody in
society recognition everything you walk
around you see surveillance cameras
they're everywhere you see barcodes
everywhere you aim your phone and it
tells you stuff about it they don't we
don't have that here we don't have the
payments being done the way here
so we're starting to fall behind and you
know it's
we're moving into an age where AI is
gonna be in charge of things and if you
have more people to study you're gonna
have AI it's gonna stretch when you have
fewer people reading now deal with the
social stratification by space
speciation do you think that it's going
to be a uber wealthy and a not the haves
and not house do you think it's gonna be
bifurcation trifurcation how many
different breaks how many years do we
have let's say 20
many years from now we're gonna have
when I'm competing which should start
along most of us are gonna be wearing
glasses and I would assume the glasses
are gonna reach the same level level of
people as phones do so we have four
billion phones in the world I had
something like that
so I'm let's say in twenty years four
billion glasses if you have a glasses on
you're having about the same life I'm
having today are you living very good
you have access to the world's knowledge
you have access to the world supply
chains you have access to the world's
jobs you have access to the world's
education you can learn how to do
anything with the glass on and you can
be entertained so that sounds like a
pretty big world and you're being taught
not to put carbon in the air so you're
maybe saving the world and you're being
taught how to build really advanced
things and if you want to have a better
job you're gonna have to learn to do
really advanced things or things that
robots just are still too expensive for
I think you know
world I want my kids live in you know
you have a shot I I can't guarantee it's
not gonna be poor
I can't guarantee he's gonna be good or
criminal but I want him to have a shot
yeah everybody have a shot I talked to a
computer scientist who teaches at-risk
kids and Chicago he says you you get
beat up if you carry around a math book
he said so I teach him on the cell phone
every drug dealer has a cell phone
yeah they don't beat up people for her
not carrying around a cell phone they'll
keep beat you up for carrying around a
math book ie people don't have a shot to
escape from their poverty III my first
interview at Microsoft was with Bill
Hill who escaped from poverty in
Scotland by going to the library every
day it was a meeting so he had a shot
you had a library exactly and we need to
do that for every kid so that they have
a shot at being a an Elon Musk cheryline
Calder you're putting a lot of your
chips into four billion people having
augmented reality headsets that give
them access to the world's knowledge and
creativity creative jobs I visited slums
in South Africa you know these are
houses with corrugated metal shack with
a dirt floor and on the solemn had a
satellite dish now these weren't the
poorest of the poor and the there if you
know they're poor but they're not
anything they don't live in a house like
yes but I they want to watch football
and be entertained you know everybody
knows the I saw a movie that just got
released it but it's not a movie it's a
VR experience but done by oculus story
studio it called wolves in the walls and
when you're playing VR and you know
oculus rift
the actress walks up to you with a
flashlight hands you a flashlight and
you take it from her and you just look
at ten minutes it's good so you're like
holy [ __ ] I'm holding on Edgemont
flashlight and you shine in her eyes and
it shines on her and her eyes are
following me like your eyes are
following me and she's talking to me
it's an AI that's talking to right it's
not all that convincing that's pretty
convincing and there's a Polaroid camera
sitting on a desk over here and you pick
up the camera and you look at that - it
goes that's cool you take a picture of
Burchell picture it's out of virtual
full right and then you hold it in your
hand
using your controller and you watch it
develop the way I watched a full-ride
camera photo develop when I was a high
school student right it's like
entertainment now you're gonna be in the
entertainment that's gonna be the
expectation soon exactly that you don't
watch Star Wars on a screen you're in
Star Wars you're walking up to a
stormtrooper and going and talking to a
droid or having a droids over those do
you want to be join our force and then
yeah see it up in here and you're gonna
see you 20 times cuz you one day you
want to be Darth Vader one day you want
to be as Princess Leia one day you want
to be you know this is gonna be moving
soon like I've seen it so I know movies
are gonna be like this so that's where
intense feeling you talk over jobs is
going so learning is going so
everybody's gonna want these eventually
everybody and from the portion of the
poor the rich in zinc that it's the
perception via there so what about in 20
years rather than it being the
perception on the glasses augmented what
if it was an actual yeah that's the true
singularity but that's too weird for me
man that's a different kind of future as
you should talk to you
I think about the next 10 years yeah
we're gonna get glasses sooner than a
prosthetic oh yeah because it's I I met
brain surgeons who work with Parkinson's
guys right Parkinson's suffers their
hands shake like that's right yeah if
you meet some able dad architects
connect they go into they do a brain
surgery
$150,000 they put a probe into your
brain with electrode at the end of it
they get it close enough to the cells
that are causing this problem they turn
it on your hands steady you can watch
this on youtube go to youtube and search
for Parkinson's surgery or Parkinson's
yeah I forget the actual thing but
there's videos of people with hands like
this they turn it on and their hands
studies that yeah so but it's $150,000
and there's that spoon that's much
cheaper that will offset the that's
great for somebody with low-grade but if
your hands are shaking like this we
should use all the techniques to solve
the brain problems yeah but where I was
going with this is you - - Jack you into
the internet like you're talking about
you're gonna have to go into my brain
that's expensive you're gonna have to
put me under a little bit and and it
causes side effects cuz you're cutting
through brain matter and we don't know
how to do versus just putting the object
here and being able to take it off
whatever yeah yeah a visual right now
we're gonna get glasses that show you
some sort of visual like the tolerances
- yeah all right the hololens puts a
visual field right in front of you and
tells you stuff so let's let's end on
just our classic questions which are do
you think we are alone in the cosmos
in your thumb is 10,000 stars galaxies
in one galaxy there's 100,000 stars so
who the [ __ ] you know if there's not
life out there somewhere I'd be highly
shocked right but the life it might be
so many light-years away that will never
ever see it it won't even see the Tesla
that just got fired do you think do you
think there are advanced civilizations
roaming the cosmos all right it's one of
those questions like Elon must say it's
this is a simulation well that this
could be a simulation I can't prove it's
not so how do you think we're in one
can't prove I'm not I can't prove I am
if we are this is a bad-ass program this
is a simulation this bad at what it's
done so well yeah um and the same thing
with life out in the world in the
universe I I can't say there's not it's
too big a universe you know I won't be
shocked if an alien comes in and says hi
you know I'm not and that's one reason
I'm not truly an atheist either I I'm
willing to believe if God showed up
right now and said hi I'd be like what's
up god yeah I wouldn't want to say that
doesn't exist but a God within you and I
do have a higher power because that
helps me deeply so and it's a very
different higher power than the
religions teach me you know my friend
had a near-death experience and she said
she saw God am I supposed to argue with
her
you know she said on the other side is
something so unexplainable that she
can't explain it to me and people
experience that on LSD or on I've been
on LSD I didn't have an experience like
that I had a lot of colors in my world I
made the red do weird [ __ ] but come on I
didn't see that worth really deep
meditation see there's so many different
ways to to touch God outside of yourself
as well so okay amazing I my mind is
expanded as so many new dimensions thank
you now I go back to Twitter
my last addiction I don't got alcohol or
drugs anymore but I got Twitter so I
want to I want to say to all the viewers
at home thank you guys so much for
tuning in if you guys had a good time on
the program please like comment
subscribe we are on patreon so if you
guys thought this was useful for you
please become a member you get benefits
like being able to ask our yes
scientists questions you get access to
early content ahead of time you get
access to exclusive content live events
ahead of time thank you guys very much
for tuning in Roberts Twitter is gonna
be down in the bio but we want to give a
big shout out to Ron fargus who is our
director he's been doing such a great
job helping out with simulation and
again thank you Robert so much thanks to
my magic Spanish so many what's up art
Bart said you've never seen TweetDeck up
on a big screen before it's like having
a Associated Press Myer machine of the
world watching alright everyone thank
you so much thanks awesome thanks thank
you super fun